wir haben die erste chance auf einen
strategiewechsel beim impfen verpasst
und sind jetzt dabei auch die zweite
große chance durch die schnell und
selbsttests zu verstolpern
da gibt es für mich nicht nur um die
schulen herrnsheimer sondern für mich
ist ein paket unter anderem mit dem test
auch mit maske auch mit hygiene konzept
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
dem schutz der wirklich gefährdeten
menschen das ist für mich ein paket das
über die schule hinaus mehr
gesellschaftliches kulturelles leben
ermöglichen kann
und für meinen geschmack konzentriert
sich die bundesregierung viel zu stark
auf die strategie wir bleiben zu hause
auf die fortsetzung des lockouts wir
hangeln uns von einem beschluss zum
nächsten das muss jetzt beendet werden
wir brauchen jetzt eine verlässliche
öffnungszeiten für das land mindestens
wenn dann regeln unter denen die
menschen dann verstehen wenn man
diszipliniert und diszipliniert und
verantwortungsbewusst ist dann gibt es
für alle auch mehr freiheit
das ist inzwischen für unser land eine
frage wirklich der politischen akzeptanz
die menschen gehen sonst der politik von
der fahne